[Music]
raise your hand if you graduated college
pretty much everyone if you raise your
hand and what needs to take a moment
take a moment and reflect on the impact
that that degree has had on your life
then that work get enabled the
opportunities that it's pulled in to
reach now I want you to imagine your 18
year old self imagine I told them you
couldn't go to college that
circumstances had changed and it wasn't
an opportunity for you how would you
feel what would you do how would you
build a career or design your resume if
you couldn't start with education this
is my first time at college now don't
worry I didn't lie on my Stanford
application at age of 18 I started
working in London as an apprentice I
learned and earned I trained as an
accountant was working full-time in
restructuring fassl day is in here I am
stood on stage it's done for Graduate
School of Business
I'm evidence that you can go
extraordinary places with an
untraditional path I succeeded because
of my own traditional path but it was
hard it was hard because of prejudices
and attitudes that exist in society
prejudices and attitudes that exist in
this room today business leaders parents
and teachers are sending the wrong
signal to young people the signal that
the only route to success is a college
degree let me tell you a story shortly
after my promotion to manager at a top
consulting firm I was rushing from one
meeting to the next I ran into one of my
favorite high school teachers we chatted
and he asked me the inevitable the
dreaded question the ready to go to
college I
I replied I'm an apprentice but before I
could finish my sentence I saw the look
of disappointment in his eyes I've lost
track of the number of times I've been
told you need to go to college to get a
good degree or but you had so much
potential rather than celebrating the
successes of people that have taken an
untraditional path we often make them
feel inadequate despite my professional
success I often feel inadequate do you
might be sat there wondering well why
should I care and I'd say you should
care for two reasons as Future Business
Leaders you are going to miss out on
great talent and as humans you have a
responsibility to the young people in
your lives so because I'm an MBA student
I'm gonna start with a business case and
then talk about the human case so the
business case we are in an employee
market organizations are struggling to
fill their ranks in 2015 5 million US
jobs went unfilled but 8.5 million
Americans were looking for jobs
anybody else see them as much talented
people locked out of the workplace
workplaces struggling to find talented
people it is in no one's best interest
to only recruit from traditional paths
by broadening your criteria you're
opening yourself to capable and diverse
candidates 80% of job applications in
the United States ask for an associate's
degree or higher yet 42% of high school
sophomores graduate college do you see
the mismatch I get it it's hard to drive
change it is hard to open up systems
that include non-traditional backgrounds
it's hard but it's doable and you can't
afford not to by opening up your
recruitment criteria you are giving
yourself a competitive talent advantage
in this tight
employment market why not be the first
mover in this current talent war now
let's talk return on investment I urge
you to become the creators and not just
the consumers of tomorrow's talent by
that I mean we all have a responsibility
to not just use skills but build skills
there is more than just a business case
for employing people with an
untraditional background there's a
business case to build apprenticeship
programs in this business case is built
upon the value-added work that you will
get from teams that work on your
projects
it's from the value add that is given
from diversify teams we know that there
is return on investment that comes with
apprenticeship models it has been proven
and has been proven to come in as little
as 18 months so although that there is
costs associated with apprenticeship
programs things like wages training
costs and program management fees you
will see a positive return on investment
businesses need to push change from the
top down as humans we need to push
change from the bottom up college for
all is disadvantaging many young people
it is having a detrimental effect on
those that learn better by doing its
disadvantaging you at those that don't
have the means or the opportunity to
attend college apprenticeship programs
allow people to learn and giving
opportunities to people from all walks
of life apprenticeship programs can be
undertaken in health care construction
finance technology media even law there
is more than one way to success there
are multiple paths but they are
currently underfunded and under
recognized we are over indexing on one
so my us to you as Future Business
Leaders is why miss out on great talent
why not push for change and put your
money where your need is why not develop
programs to hire and train the
leaders of your organization and as
humans we need to challenge our elitist
attitudes that equate not having a
degree to not being capable we need to
recognize that apprenticeship programs
and work experience are just as valuable
as college degrees so I'm going to leave
you with three challenges I challenge
you to change the way you think about
non-traditional backgrounds I challenge
you to change the way you talk about
success and finally next time a resume
crosses your desk I challenge you not to
jump straight to education but instead
dig into experience and benefit from a
diverse young workforce thank you
[Applause]
[Music]